keith Ellison of Minnesota is in some
obscure c-list Democrat he is Deputy
Chair of the Democratic National
Committee he nearly won the chairmanship
outright last year he's a champion still
of the party's progressive wing he's a
great favor of the grassroots he
deserves to be regarded as one of the
Democratic Party's top thought leaders
such as they are yesterday Ellison
tweeted this quote at Moon Palace books
and I just found the book that will
strike fear in the heart of Donald Trump
and the book Ellison was talking about
is called antifa
the anti-fascist handbook why would that
book strike fear into the heart of the
president uh knighted States well maybe
because that book advocates for
political violence against people like
Donald Trump and his supporters the
author is a man named Mark Bray and he
writes that violence is quote a small
the vital sliver of anti fascist
activity elsewhere in the text he
approvingly quotes antiva activist who
says this of his political opponents
quote you fight them with fists so you
don't have to fight them with knives you
fight them with knives you don't have to
fight them with guns you fight them with
guns so you don't have to fight them
with tanks that's about as explicit a
justification for political violence as
there is Bray also in the book by the
way it's acts freedom of speech he
endorses the tactic of silencing those
he disagrees with now of course Bray
claims to fight fascism but he is
himself a fascist keith Ellison believes
Bray's work is admirable he said so now
if you're shocked by this you haven't
followed Ellison's career for very long
he has a long history of saying
repugnant things and backing extremist
causes back in 1989 Ellison wrote that
the Constitution existed only for white
people he referred to it as quote their
constitution calling it quote the best
evidence of a white racist conspiracy to
subjugate other peoples that's the
Constitution the United States Ellison
has spoken favorably meanwhile of
cop-killer Assata Shakur he said he was
quote praying that Fidel Castro's
communist regime in Cuba would not be
forced to X tried her back to the United
States as a law student at the
University of Minnesota Ellison wrote a
column calling for the creation of a
separate black ethno State this
the man who was now second in command of
the entire Democratic Party now that
ought to bother Republicans in
Independence it should terrify Democrats
most voters don't support cop-killing
racial separatism political violence
abolishing freedom of speech and they
tend to flee from politicians and
parties that do support those things
Democrats at this point assume they're
gonna make major gains in this year's
midterm elections purely on the strength
of the president's low poll numbers so
at this point they're happy to ignore
haters like keith Ellison Ellison
opposes Trump and that's enough for now
but what would happen if Democrats
actually did win and got power back in
November suddenly Ellison's views would
matter a lot Pete he and people like him
would have real control over your life
are you ready for that